a lot of disadvantages of only having
like one kid one of the disadvantages I
think is that is that now because it's
only one kid and and hopefully there are
two parents uh now you really have to
you have to be very careful about sort
of manufacturing opportunities for your
child your single child to have
responsibilities and I think a lot of
parents of only one kid don't
manufacture those those opportunities
and so they end up with a really spoiled
kid I want my
uh but when you have a lot of kids you
don't you don't really have to
manufacture it it's just it naturally
comes with the life that you're living
that they're going to take on
responsibilities and hopefully that will
help them become less selfish people and
it's true that you know kids need
attention from parents uh they want a
lot of attention and you need to give
them your attention but it is definitely
possible to give a kid too much
attention absolutely and that's another
problem when you only have one kid the
risk that they receive way too much
attention is uh is very high